pauleta mais c'est jean françois lamour
volume les républicains merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la défense
monsieur le ministre
demain le nouveau site du ministère
défense veille inauguré par le président
de la république comme non voulue
nicolas sarkozy et françois fillon
les trois états-majors et l'ensemble des
administrations vont être ainsi réunis à
balard pour plus d'efficacité et de
cohésion et nous nous en réjouissons
avec mon collègue fribourgeois
mais ce regroupement va également être
l'opportunité pour l'état de céder un
certain nombre d'emprise immobilière
parisienne en particulier céda l'objet
de ma question monsieur le ministre
ses ventes doivent rapporter 624
millions d'euros d'ici à 2019 pour le
ministère de la défense
et vous dites je vous cite avoir prévu
large mais force est de constater que
nous sommes aujourd'hui loin du compte
en effet les principales emprise qui se
situe d'ailleurs à quelques centaines de
mètres d'ici au plein coeur de paris
sont composés d'une part de l'hôtel
l'artillerie qui est aujourd'hui évalué
à 104 millions d'euros mais qui fait
l'objet de négociations très largement
au delà du prix évoqué par l'homme très
par france domaine de l'ordre de 60
millions d'euros
l'autre principal élément immobiliers
cédilot saint germain qui était évoquée
aussi à 301 millions d'euros et qui va
faire l'objet vous le savez d'une très
importante décote du fait du souhait de
la mairie de paris que d'y construire
plus de 50 % de logements sociaux
monsieur le ministre il serait
inacceptable que vous validiez ses
conditions de vente qui confine à la
gabegie et que le gouvernement brade
ainsi quelques-uns des éléments les plus
rémunérateurs du patrimoine immobilier
d'état c'est la raison pour laquelle je
vous demande de garantir à la
représentation nationale que les ventes
prévues
ce seront alors juste paix et ne
priverons pas le budget de la défense de
subsides dont vous en conviendrez
elle a plus que jamais besoin merci
monsieur le député la parole et à
monsieur mise la défense
monsieur jean yves le drian monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs le
député monsieur le député jean françois
lamour merci de cette question je sais
que vous voudrez préoccuper beaucoup de
ces ressources immobilières sur le
budget de la défense
je vous rappelle au passage je rappelle
à la représentation nationale qu'elle
concerne 0 6% du budget de la défense
depuis que les ressources
exceptionnelles ont été budgétés à la
demande du président de la république et
du premier ministre ce qui veut dire que
0 6% du budget de 32 milliards ça
correspond à peu près à 200 millions
d'euros par an mais ce n'est pas une
raison
et vous avez raison de le souligner de
d'être laxiste sur ses recettes la qui
contribuent aussi à l' équilibre
budgétaire et à l'effort
d'investissement de du ministère de la
défense
alors vous êtes interrogatif sur notre
capacité à vendre
je voudrais simplement vous signaler
comme je l'avais déjà fait dans le débat
budgétaire qu'en ce qui concerne les
prévisions de recettes en 2016 qui sont
de 200 millions d'euros
elles seront totalement réalisé en
raison d'abord de recettes
supplémentaires que nous avons pu
acquérir en 2015 parce que nous avons
bien vendu des implantations militaires
sur paris et je suis convaincu que les
recettes que nous aurons en 2016 vous
permettront sans difficulté d'atteindre
le chiffre inscrit dans le budget nous
faisons preuve et sur l'autel de
l'artillerie et sur l'îlot saint-germain
comme sur bellechasse
comme sur la pépinière d'une très grande
vigilance sur les prix pour que le
ministère de la défense
on trouve là des ressources financières
significatif et la décote dont vous
parlez s'applique sur eux pour le mit sa
défense sur les ventes en en province
mais pas sur les ventes
à paris ce qui fait que la prudence qui
nous caractérise nous permet d'envisager
avec sérénité le budget 2016
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
un monsieur gabriel